there are ancient windmills in a chiffon
village which is located in northeast
part of Iran
what makes national an ancient windmill
unique is that they are still
operational
one of the main characteristic of the
area is the strong wind that blow across
it as a result of the natural elements
in the area of Engineers have been a
part of religious landscape and have
been used throughout mid-century this
windmill as it can be seen are built on
top of the hill overlooking the village
which not only are carefully designed to
protect the village from the devastating
winds but also utilize the wind power as
a source of energy
[Music]
the people willing to have been
corrected that is 1000 years ago are
generally made of natural elements such
as clean straw and this technology has
most probably been transferred to the
west from dis regime despite the long
history of this technology in Iran today
mr. Latta body is the last remaining
hair summon residing in Mexican for our
generation of those who kept the secret
of this ancient earth and pass it on to
the next generation he as the custodian
of windmills have devoted his life to
the windmills and while visiting them
painted a new pal Phoenician Vindhya
Khan has tirelessly protecting
unfortunately none of this chamber or
local people as shown desire to take up
the job from him and also he has no a
pentas to home he can't pass on this
historic legacy enormously emotional get
the chance to do good dude kannada nisha
katakana Babu kana will fall on Conor in
another you know how mr. Misskelley
bordick in rabbinic in the area here in
Omaha
hamaji Thomas with the Maharaja of
Muharram villas and amiable
[Music]
[Music]